foreign
get started who wants the only 24 or 27
by 40 rashima roushuman film series that
says
Ernie sucks dick for pennies
Ernie sucks dicks Ernie is it true do
you suck dick for pennies
I said he does it for free bud
who wants it
right there down in front there you go
careful now I don't break and [__] like
three times uh and then whoever asks the
best question or uh is gonna get this
test pressings
um which he explained to me which I
didn't know what it was
um I guess like 20 of these are made for
each album uh to test them out to make
sure they work and such so it's pretty
rare signed by peeps signed by uh all of
my product
peeps so best question best question
gets it
what if someone get what about the best
answer what do I get you can ask it
um so yeah man that was uh that was
awesome I I again I wanted to go call
the wife because uh I started talking or
I don't know if anyone knows here my
wife's pregnant we're gonna have a baby
boy thank you
we're having a baby boy in a month um
but she had had to tell me some stuff
she called right before we were supposed
to be up here for the intro
um and my point of this long story short
um is I was like I gotta go I gotta go
do the intro with Josh I gotta go
um so I really wanted to call her back
to like find out some information but I
really wanted that like sitting through
an hour and a half at least of the
um
there's ghosts um like an hour and a
half at like the documentary is so good
dude I I again I really want to finish
watching it right thank you I appreciate
that
uh it really made me want to sit and
watch the whole thing and I would have
sat and watched the whole thing if I
wasn't like really focused on the
documentary but at the same time the
back of my head's like I gotta go find
out what happened you know so uh anyway
I just wanted to say that to you I
didn't get to say that to you out front
because you were too busy writing [__]
on about Ernie's loving the [__] it's
all true yes
um but yeah I don't know if we just
started do you want to say anything or
do you want to just open up for Q and A
name uh no I mean thank you all for
coming it means the absolute World
um especially the Parks family
um everything was a labor of love we did
this all everything both movies entirely
DIY Park stock for 45k uh wrong reasons
for 92 and
um you know you don't do [__] like that
unless it means the world to you so I
had a lot of good friends that came out
and helped out they didn't make a
goddamn dime but they own a bigger chunk
of the movie than I do so if we get any
kind of success they win so
yeah I saw the part
um the the part uh in the movie with and
I'm horrible at names the gentleman when
uh when parks's son lays on the couch
it's the guy that does the the mouth
Garmin no I know
that would be awesome I'm like I know
that guy he's been in a couple of our
movies
no he's in the he's in there like
Talladega Nights and stuff oh uh David
keckner yes thank you that was that's
awesome
I met him at uh the uh Hollywood improv
very nice that's very sweet that he came
and did it this was in the movie
um and the music at the end is awesome
um I was rocking out I missed some of
the movie because I went to get ice
cream I'm sorry I was calling my name
man
he was rocking out so hard he almost
broke the test yes yes so don't forget
about that
um dude we can open it up or rocking
who's got a question they have a
question
my question for you is I know
so what was your like first reaction oh
yes that's a great question uh so like I
was saying earlier
um the cool thing for me is I got I was
lucky enough
um I didn't get to meet him on red State
and it made sense to me but I didn't get
to be in red state with uh Kevin because
Kevin was that was his first movie he
had done that wasn't uh you know of you
ask Universe movie with uh you know
Dante Randall and the Hulk stuff like
that and he was worried if he put me in
that movie as another character people
would it like be into the movie and the
whole Parks aspect of it and and
everything that's going on and then
James would pop up as like one of the
um I don't want to say it was occult
members or whatever members religious
religious Fanatics and then people are
like there's snoots to the news you know
like and it would ruin it so Kevin's
like look man I really of course want to
put you in it but I can't I'm worried
and some but anyway my point is but then
on Tusk it was great because um I was I
got to be in that I got to work on that
movie
um I just came out and I helped Kevin uh
do stuff I produced it and I got to like
work and be on the movie the whole time
and hang out with Parks a little bit and
stuff my first reaction for Parks again
Kevin had talked about how awesome he is
um because of uh red stain
um so you know I was like the I was like
the expectation was there so and he like
when I met him he's super nice and then
getting to watch him it was cool because
I met him on set said hello I didn't get
to hang out with him too much at that at
first but then watching him work it was
awesome like
um I think the first scene I I got to
come and see
um that we shot was at the table in Tusk
when they're at the dinner table and
just to listen to this speech and
everything I mean it was amazing so
again it was it was awesome it was I'm
lucky enough to because after that I
didn't see him after like Josh you know
I spent a lot of time with them after I
just got to spend that time with them on
Tusk so I'm I'm happy and feel lucky
that I got to to be there for that so
well and you directed uh walrus yes I
mean like you were the one in front of
like the camera like you know guiding
essentially being the narrator through
the whole entire documentary yeah it was
fun it was fun and that's like a lot
what what I got to do for that because
again I think Kevin was still nervous
about me being in on camera besides Zach
and Mary I guess is the only move but
and it makes sense to me but I told him
I was like dude next movie I want to be
the lead thank you so oh my gosh what
the [__] Ernie thanks can I get one dude
thank you I I didn't even want to do
that bro I was [__] like trying to
rip that poster up thanks bro
thank you sir thank you for that I would
love something thank you young man
hurry up [__]
um
I love looking out though and seeing
everyone here I tell I keep telling
Kevin man if I didn't live in LA and uh
we were having our family and stuff I
was like I would be working here I would
be like Kev you gotta let me work here
it seems like such a great thing and I
know you guys have been coming Kevin's
been doing all these events and I see
many familiar faces so I'm assuming you
guys as far as I hear you guys have been
coming to a lot of the events a bunch of
you guys
um and it just seems like so much fun
I'm like man I want to like build a
little apartment in the back here in the
theater or some [__] and then Josh
starts teasing me you know I stream on
Twitch and I play all the time fortnite
and Call of Duty and he's like dude I
set up the [__] PS5 to the screen and
we're playing on this big screen anyway
I don't know that's a whole other story
are we allowed to say where you live
when you're out here where you say where
are you oh yeah you can yeah yeah he
sleeps at the stash
he's got a little little man cave in
there I do Ernie thank
Ernie had put like uh cleared out an
area upstairs there's a room where they
had all the pops and they I asked him if
he could clear it out and put a bed in
there a couch or something and there was
a futon at the office so Ernie was nice
enough to drag it over to the stash and
he even ran internet upstairs for me and
eat landline because I like the Stream
So he I have a desk in my setup for
streaming and he like he like ran a
ethernet cable up to the thing and like
so very sweet Ernie um but yeah so I I
do stay there if it's like one night
I'll stay at the stash the only downside
there's no shower so I haven't showered
in like a day which isn't that long okay
maybe
who's next right there
there was good eye
oh that's a good one yeah no there's uh
looks like someone's winning that
[__] record oh [__] right
um I love Venture Brothers and in the uh
the house uh that they're in cat's house
in Nick's house there's a uh a pilot
from the pilot episode it's actually
like an original animatic from it so
there's that there's a bunch of like
punk rock Easter eggs but the Venture
Brothers is the one that I'm proud that
I stuck in there that
yeah good excuse to watch again what'd
you say Connor
I have it tattooed on my leg I do wait
did you say Buck Rogers no uh Venture
Brothers no no but you said something
after that you said the butt something
he said Squidbillies no you said I'm
telling you you said something you said
what is punk rock oh yes punk rock sorry
when you said punk rock for some reason
I heard Buck Rogers I was like [__] yeah
I did
[Laughter]
great eye
down in front
oh
um narrative is a scary Beast
um trying to you know
um
direct people in a way like it's easy
with like docs you can just chop it up
throw on b-roll you gotta like a lot of
outs uh it was pretty terrifying and
specifically because like I love uh Jim
jarmash I love like long Runners I love
like long tags so to uh to commit myself
to Long tanks and not have the out of
editing it took like a lot of takes it
took like a lot of practice a lot of
rehearsal and it took really great
actors but it was terrifying as [__]
thank you I did
I appreciate it did you edit yourself
too and color and sound design for the
movie yeah oh that's awesome bro yeah
thank you it is interesting I don't even
edit I don't edit like physically edit
but I I realized
um
you know from like Kevin being on all
Kevin's movie and Kevin edits himself
when I when I directed my movie like it
was cool because while I was filming I
realized when I was directing and doing
the scenes I I was editing in my head
sure like again I don't edit but I knew
like oh this is gonna probably cut from
here to there from there to there so
again I feel like for you it must have
been the same like you just said like
where you're like oh I don't need to
have him walk down the aisle even though
it was in the script he comes to the
door and walks through the aisle you're
like I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna
apply cut from the door to the stage you
know whatever yeah for sure I probably
go the opposite way though where I shoot
way too much coverage just in case like
I [__] something up fair enough yeah
somebody walks in the wrong way or I
shot like at the wrong angle I always
cover mine makes sense and again you
actually physically at it so you need
that so that makes sense yeah I know how
dumb the shooter is yeah
I saw
uh has anybody seen holidays Kevin's
movie
uh she's in the short and like she never
really talked about wanting to act
before but when I saw her in that I was
like how do we not make a vehicle
entirely around her so she uh you know
not only did she like learn guitar which
I insisted she'd do so it was accurate
she created her own music we started a
band
and like she took it so [__]
seriously like she she can't half-ass
anything it's really like intimidating
um but yeah no she [__] crushed every
aspect of it was like she chained
herself to a bed for 24 hours just to
see what it what she would feel like
she's [__] insane and
and that was all her singing in the end
right yeah that's all her so good it's
it's really cool
um yeah I know he's had his hand up a
punch stew
Hey sir
really you know excellent excellent work
oh thank you so much Stu
do it
yeah good eye
can that is a uh early uh what do you
call a test shot what do you get when
you're an actor I'm bad at this oh uh uh
test screening I guess like the photo
headshot early headshot that is
superimposed into a play that that
character did in the early 90s and like
if you look at it and you can pause it
and freeze frame it that's exactly what
it is what a great eyes do
wait so who was it as headshot of for
yourself yeah Ralph gave me all his
early test shots so like we go through
our headshots all right yeah so we go
through it all and we use them a lot and
we just like changed the name in the
corner I love that that's great we had
no budget we had to be creative no I
love it that's great
of himself it totally does he's a
narcissistic [__]
it truly
thank you so much Stu
I appreciate it who's the young lady
that was in bed with uh with Ralph there
was three young ladies uh oh one is my
friend Ansley one I think we found a
porn star on accident because she's just
like like at one point a girl goes down
on him but it's like that's the one I
saw and he's on the phone yes that's so
nice that that lady like has disappeared
from the planet
um and like she came and she's like look
I don't do head on camera we're like all
right we'll just have live underneath
the sheet I think she actually meant she
didn't want to do head on camera
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no I can say that
young man
thank you
uh balls and stupidity are synonyms you
know like at some point just be dumb
enough to not say no just keep going
never be able to back down like just I
always put it like this like there's a
brick wall and I'm gonna hit my head
against it until either it or I fall
like I just I don't [__] care it's
all I got
um as far as like how I got everybody go
work your ass off volunteer do PA jobs
meet as many people as possible be nice
be nice be a good person
um and just you know uh meet as many
people as you can as many people that
are as hungry as you are and just form a
collective Circle and try to use that to
your benefit like everybody exploit each
other but like always work on each
other's projects
does that make sense
yeah no worries man do you do you need a
job we can work together I need to
exploit people at all times
give me your card
uh that young man
yes sir
he was
yeah
what was the project
yeah everybody's came up to me and just
like I know that guy I was like yes you
do
oh what this is on you bro wait sorry
what happened you gotta pick somebody oh
oh you want me to pick him I was like
did I get asked someone down I'm sitting
here I was trying to picture I'm like
wait he was in Adventures of babysitting
okay young man
Kevin as the cameraman yes
uh truthfully I just put him in this is
me I put my camo shorts on them and I
put a vest on them like go you're me
because that's just like you know an
easy way to direct somebody's just like
act like I do
um because you know I I love the boy to
death but I knew he wasn't going to read
the role like before because he's busy
he's busy so I was like just come up
here I'm gonna work you like a puppet
and he did and it worked out give him
the easiest role exactly yeah totally
make it an easy request because it's a
big request to have them come out and do
stuff
uh I see a green shirt back there Chris
thank you thank you
so I just want to ask you about how that
scene came together from an editing
perspective from a writing perspective
just your thoughts on that uh I mean at
some point like you've gotta and I mean
honestly that you could talk to uh
addiction a lot stronger than I could
um but at some point I feel like you
have to save yourself it can't you your
friends can set you up to prosper
everybody can help you I can have a
support network but at some point if you
don't want to do the work you're [__]
like that's what it is it has to be your
self-deployment you have to be ready
yeah for sure so for me that was like
the like the authentic bit where she
does choose for herself that she wants
to go that route as far as shooting I
mean I think we did that on a
stabilizer so like anything we did on a
stabilizer was a pain in my dick and I
regret because I'm just hand holding
like a 25 pound thing for hours on end
um but yeah
right there
I did Matt row bottom
yeah that'd be me
uh Matt is a great friend of mine he
concentrated more on lighting and stuff
and I concentrated more on camera and
Camera opping
um I don't know how many people are
familiar with filmmaking but to direct
and camera off but simultaneously is
[__] impossible but we we got through
it because we had covid and like covet
meant that we had limited budget and we
had limited people that could be on set
so we did everything with the
five-person crew which means everybody
wore a lot of hats
will you explain uh just case anyone
here doesn't know what a Dutch shot is
oh a Dutch shot is like yeah when you
take a thing and you make it slightly
Askew usually uh for like intimidation
or paranoia uh very like uh predominant
in German expressionism
um I I'm a huge German expressionism fan
save all those shots you decided at that
point not only were you filming it you
decided hey this what I want I want yes
to be honest I want it to be slightly
off axis nice yeah
nothing is
so are you saying you liked it or you
just did it oh cool thank you
nice
yes
uh it is good eye yeah we didn't have
access to him that day because he was
probably on another project or something
um but yeah they're slightly longer hair
in the back yeah no good eye
yeah sorry and we we couldn't afford
afford them for the day probably did you
not want the gentleman who was under the
mask was like I ain't cutting my hair
[__] that [__] dude we tried to pull it
back but I think some fell out and like
it's so black and white grainy I'm like
nobody will ever notice till you ruin my
[__] night yeah you [__]
everyone loved the movie until this [__]
got pointed out
who earns boo earns
uh no there's a lot of stuff like that
that's like not technically right with
the movie and there's like there's a
couple shots that like break the 360 the
180 rule thank you
um and like you know it's at some point
you have to decide whether you want to
go back and get all those resources and
shoot it again or if you know if you
don't have the resources you just gotta
do what you gotta do and at some point
we ran out of resources a long time ago
that that to me it's like I've been
doing this now uh I guess it's been 30
years or so and it still seems so
complicated to me but but I know it's
not just me because I've been on sets
where people I know have worked um you
know worked on movies but a lot like 10
years but the whole idea of like hey
you're talking to me so be on this side
yeah yeah of the camera right and then
when you turn around say it again
yeah it's so as I still don't get I'm
like no no I think it's the other side
no wait maybe it's no see I do righty
Lefty I'm like if somebody's always on
the right they're on the right in both
shots if somebody's always on the left
or in the left in both shot so I call it
right he Lefty
love it
so uh I didn't see I see him somewhere
back there fine green shirt and then
someone else
it's getting the lights right here so
everything's pretty bright some [__]
installed these spotlights
closer
to do it again
like together
that'd be great right
um I definitely want to I would love to
direct another movie
um thanks
um what I would like to do different
for me because when I directed mine I
was I was one of the main characters so
I had to be on camera a bunch which made
it a little bit harder but not as it was
still fun and I enjoyed it very much but
I just feel like I really want to do it
again and not be on camera so much
because it was like okay you know let's
block this out we'd set the camera up
and I'd like look I'm gonna have me run
down this way and then this person comes
in and do this and I'll be like all
right you got that cool I'm gonna go get
dressed and get makeup and hair you know
and then come back and so it was a lot
yeah and then we had that sometimes I'd
watch playback and then sometimes I'd
like luckily I had that gentleman who
produced it Dominic Burns who was he's
directed a bunch of movies in London
um like movies with Van Damme and all
this stuff so I I sometimes would be
like hey what'd you think he'd like dude
that definitely was good you got it like
let's move on and stuff so but yes I
hopefully I definitely want to do it
again and I still would like to be in it
but next time I'd put myself as like
yeah like four maybe four scenes of like
rope
you really want that Rogue coming yeah
I'm not going anywhere I this is what I
do till I die
yes let's go
hey buddy yeah yeah
thank you
no
actually it didn't come out looking
nearly as good as I'd hoped like I can
pick this film apart like a hundred and
a hundred thousand different ways
what's that
for sure I totally agree with that yeah
it's um we had 92k and like because we
shot during covet a quarter that like
went away immediately and then you deal
with like sag which is Union we can't
get away from that nobody else was Union
but like you know you pay for people's
accommodations you pay for the place the
rental place the we own our own gear
which is the only place we kind of got
off like decently uh but like you know
we definitely didn't use the 92k as well
as we would have if we didn't do it
during covid we would have had a much
better looking movie uh we would have
had the ability to do more takes do more
options shoot more coverage not shooting
it in a 10 by 10 room where you can't
roll away the walls it was [__]
nightmare
um yeah no it's I appreciate you saying
it looks good I all I see are the
failings what did you film what did you
shoot it on uh Ursa 4.6 K G2 so is that
a camera that you wind up spending money
on because you're like we have to have
this camera or is that something you
settled for because of money that is
something I settled for for money we
probably could have rented like an area
or something like that which you would
have wanted to you're saying if you had
the option yes but what I get with the
uh Ursa the Black Magic Camera is I got
to keep it afterwards oh so I didn't get
paid for the movie but I got like a good
amount of gear afterwards so now I could
take that camera and make money other
places I love that there you go
um yeah
hello sorry
thank you
uh we had a project lined up I don't
know if it's going to work out yet or
not uh but uh you know I'm I'm have one
script done that I need to like revisit
uh called uh dally Ripple goes wrong
it's based on F Scott Fitzgerald short
story which is in the public domain
um that is something I'm going to
reapproach now that I got a little bit
of time to work on stuff and the other
thing is I've been writing a heist movie
for like the last couple years that can
be done like super down and dirty for
like probably 300K and with the idea of
it sounds so [__] audacious uh doing
a Trilogy of them but like stepping up
the budget each time with like the
success from the prior one did you say
an ice movie Heist Heist Heist I keep
hearing the worst I'm like a nice movie
I'm probably not on the mic well enough
but it's a heist movie yeah oh I want to
I want to I want to read that yeah I
want to be part of this you could be in
it bro we could make please let's go
there you go that's our next thing and
we could Co I you direct the first one
and I can direct part two I'm all about
it and then we'll co-direct three done
done
you guys got it right here first
can I get down now or is anybody else
hey there we go can I get down
we still have to give it away uh all
right this will be the last question
let's do that so we can uh so I hope
it's a good one
what is that
dude
like show my move screen my movie and
then
oh for he's a jolly Cafe
uh uh you saw and loved it well thank
you I thought you were like you looked
at me and looked away like I loved it
I was like thanks bro
thank you very much thank you I would
totally do that again I I just haven't I
think uh you know this has all been just
getting rolled out the movie theater
just happened and movies are starting to
get screened here
um
but and then right now we're focused on
the baby boy coming so yeah so but I
would totally love to do that and it's a
great idea like I would love to uh oh
yeah I would love to show my movie here
do we have a name yet you know we're on
we have we have three names we haven't
decided yet the three names were sort of
it's definitely one of these three Remy
Roman
or Lucian
[Music]
so and the middle name's gonna be Lee so
I like Lucian because it's Lucian Lee
Muse and Logan's name is Logan Lee so
Double L and yes
Lucian
I'm going there I said I said I I'm more
towards Lucian the wife's teetering on
Roman and Lucy and she's still not it's
like 50 50 for her
Lucy and I'm gonna break yo we were
there and everyone said it so we have to
do it you know that one [__]
said you gotta name your kid
no Logan's uh having the baby brother or
the name it's uh she's uh she's goes
back and forth sometimes she's excited
she's at school the teachers told us me
the other day that she was like super
stoked telling me when I'm having a baby
brother I'm having a baby brother I
can't wait and in other times all of a
sudden I'll be like like I
I got this diaper bag for the baby and
it's a tactical diaper bag it has kevlar
in it right I thought it was really cool
so I get the bag but they gave me a free
patch that said Mommy and Daddy and she
was she saw she I opened it up and like
the things fell out she picked up she's
like Mommy Daddy she's like what about
Logan she's like I don't want a brother
anymore like so she goes she has her
moments so but for the most part she's
excited so but yeah I'm really excited
about my attention
I just see what a a Boy comes out from
you like that's gonna be an interesting
Dynamic I'm waiting to see I'm seeing
you know the wife's excited because she
feel Logan's always like Mommy can you
leave the room for a bit because I want
to hang out with Daddy alone you know
and it really gets to her sometimes so
she's like you know what this is gonna
be my baby because he's a boy and
assuming mama's boy you know I'm saying
I was like we'll see you know what I'm
saying we'll see
um but we'll see I'm excited I'm very
excited but the movie part the movie
thing's a great idea so hopefully you
know after things the baby's born in a
few months I think that's a good idea so
um and now we're gonna pick the winner
four
what do you think was the best question
I thought I like the one question I
think the lady left though that I liked
it okay hello
eats didn't you very crafty very crafty
you [__] Bamboozled us
that's my vote I think yeah yeah I agree
I think I agree there was another there
was another couple goodies well they're
all good they're all good questions but
except for were you pointed out the
thing that I [__] up on
you
[Laughter]
oh [__] okay
um here you go you are the winner winner
chicken dinner uh everybody give it up
for Jason Muse I couldn't have done this
without him what's up thank you yes
thank you guys for coming man uh like I
said keep an eye out for my movie coming
out Josh did an awesome again I I wanna
I need to see the rest of the
documentary I don't know if you can slip
me a TV
guys thank you for coming be safe have a
great night
[Music]
foreign